this is store from timcast.com going
into greater detail on the Congressional
hearings we saw with Matt Tybee and
Michael schellenberger they say
shellenberger along with his for with
former Twitter with fellow Twitter files
reporter Matt taibi appeared before the
select subcommittee on the weaponization
of the federal government regarding
their findings in the Twitter files
quote I've never worked on an issue
where so frequently while doing it I
just had chills going up my spine
because of what I was seeing happening
Schoenberger said I never thought in my
own country that freedom of speech would
be threatened in this way it's just
frightening when you get into it it's
amazing because the Democrats and what
was it that delegate woman not even a
member of Congress yeah smearing and
lying and acting like this stuff isn't
happening right before our very eyes
with Tucker Carlson he puts out video
definitively proving the police give an
escort to uh chansley the Q Shaman
walking him around the building trying
to open doors for him and the media
comes out in lockstep along with Mitch
McConnell and they all say no no don't
believe Your Lying Eyes Tucker Carlson
is speaking against the the the uh
what should we call it the Enclave right
and the White House said he's not
credible that's right so don't listen to
him now we have Michael schellenberger
leave your eyes yeah don't believe your
eyes we have the Twitter files
definitive evidence that the government
was working in tandem there's portals
Twitter Twitter built a government
reporting portal and then I see this
Democrat being like was there ever any
instance where the government demanded
they take something down and Sean Burger
is like yes he's like they are directed
them take it down he goes they did he
goes they emailed saying like hey
flagging these for reviews oh they're
just flagging them though okay thank you
for clarifying you think a request is a
demand
oh I know it was insane I mean it was
actually one of the most lit
Congressional hearings yeah it was crazy
in a while it was really we've actually
watched the whole thing
yeah I mean anything I can tell you
yeah here we go here we go this is
Plaskett yeah to praise him for his work
this isn't just a matter of what data
was giving into these so-called
journalists before us now
look at that type he gives this look to
Michael schellenberger like did she say
so called questions about where musk got
the financing
congresswoman we know she's not she's a
delegate she's not even right you ready
for this it's a clown show so Glenn
Greenwell tweeted this 18 seconds he
should have tweeted the full thing
because Matt taibi mentions he's got 30
years in the industry but it was amazing
here's what he was here's what he said
that time was spent at Rolling Stone
magazine ranking member Plaskett
um I'm not a so-called journalist I've
won the national magazine award the I
have stone award for independent
journalism and I've written 10 books
including four New York Times New York
Times bestsellers
uh I'm not yeah there you go you're not
even listening to his answer right Jim
Jordan in the background just being like
Oh my goodness these people are evil
there's just there's no question and you
know now that Ian's not here you know
what I say when the cats are away the
muscle but now that Ian's not here we
can all sit here in agreement the
Democrats are evil right yes yes
absolutely they're in furtherance of
moloch now Ian sitting in the room going
like I should have been on the show
tonight I wouldn't I wouldn't say
evilness you wouldn't say withholding
exculpatory evidence
I would say doing that is evil so you
don't think the people who did that were
evil I don't know I hesitate to put
judgment on a person's heart so you know
I'm a softy like so you're saying that
you're probably even Redemption yeah I I
believe in Redemption too but I got to
tell you a person who acts who engages
in evil activities is an evil person I
think they should probably be put in
prison I mean these are these are
criminals look man there's a guy who
goes into a bank and he robs it
demanding one dollar and then the cops
come and they say Sir you're under
arrest and he explains the reason he did
it was because he has cancer and he
can't get medical treatment but if he's
in prison they'll be forced to give him
medical treatment and he didn't want to
die maybe he was trans and that is not
an evil person that is that is a
horrifying story of and a very sad one
but he committed a crime and he should
go to prison you have people who are
hungry or who typically want or need
things I would not call that evil if a
guy goes to a supermarket and he steals
some food because he's hungry I wouldn't
call that evil Jean if a guy goes to a
supermarket and grabs food brings it out
back and destroys it because he's it's
funny and he does it in front of
starving people I would say that's evil
that's evil yeah and that person is evil
I would say that Stacy Plaskett and
Sylvia Garcia I think they are stupid I
think they are stupid moronic people I
think that I don't think they even have
enough uh sense of personhood to be evil
I think they're just completely it's the
banality of you stupid
like Sylvia Garcia the Texas
representative he's saying useful idiots
she's out there she's talking about like
oh did you file this with Twitter first
she doesn't even know of course Ian said
the other night that he thinks I asked
him what evil was and he said strangling
a cat because you're you enjoy watching
it suffer that's an evil action you do
you think a person who strangles cats
for fun is evil they go around doing it
consistently knowing it's wrong if they
find pleasure enjoying it yes I think
intentionally doing what if they were
developmentally disabled and they were
laughing uh Strangling a cat is that
evil you mean like enough Mice and Men
when Lenny kills that girl I I don't
know I guess was Lenny evil I mean
so if a person like does a level of
intelligence absolve someone of their
evil actions
I wonder if it does that's an
interesting I say no does evil require
intelligence I do not think so I I think
whether any kind of create like there is
a degree of evil in cats I knew that
that's torture other animals for fun and
pleasure not for sustenance so but we
think we know this we know this about
them are cats evil yep I mean to a
certain degree to a certain degree they
are so so I'll put it I'll put it this
way I'll put it I'll put it this way I
disagree I think they might be scampi
dogs can't be yeah so so I'll put it
this I'll put it this way I'll put it
this way that if is is that person evil
in their heart be if they're not making
that decision themselves of their own
volition
um yes that's that's a moral question
but if you are on the receiving end if
you are someone who is subject to a
regime that's controlled by people like
Stacy Plaskett if you are subject to a a
pit bull attack from your neighbor right
then it is within your right to act to
stop the evil which is occurring to you
I just got to give a shout out to Brett
ain't dead in the member chat saying no
cats are based and then they're posting
Focus emojis look we like cats but
there's like a degree of there's like a
hundred cats here but I've watched bocus
sit outside staring at a crippled mouse
that he crippled and then it it's laying
there hyperventling and shaking and then
when it when it gets up and slows that's
crawling away he stands up and gets
ready and then when it runs he whacks it
again and then it just sits there that's
shaking again oh that's that and I'm
like yo cats are evil dude that's like
that's so like horrible he's not hungry
so he doesn't need to destroy this it
was just fun because it's suffering
that's right cats do that cats I knew
this woman in college and she told me
about her dad who when their cat had
trying to date girls like that but we
like cats though because and put them in
the freezer we killed them in the
freezer that's evil too I think that was
evil I knew this man who was but what
but were they were they mentally
challenged the cat or the dad the dad I
don't think her name was Jessica but she
was from New Zealand actually so the way
she said it was Jessica I mean look when
it comes to it when it comes to the law
we actually don't hold someone
responsible for a crime if they are
developmentally or mentally disabled we
actually say you know this person is not
capable of of going on the stand and
defending themselves the actions they
committed were outside of their
understanding so we're not going to put
them to death you know I don't there was
this woman you'd see this woman who
killed her children and now she's her
attorneys are saying well she's mentally
ill in Medicine Massachusetts yeah so
she shouldn't face the death penalty
that story man that's brutal I think
that's evil I think even if you're
mentally ill you can be evil if I think
about it in terms of mothers who kill
children I think I think people can be
redeemed I think people can be
apologetic I think people can realize
what they did was wrong but I I think
she belongs to mental institution if you
commit evil acts you are evil I mean I'm
shocked she hasn't killed herself I I
think she belongs to minerals usually
that's what that's what we'll say with
that what they did to the January 6
defendants is definitively undeniably
factually objectively evil yes I think
that's true they withheld exculpatory
evidence violating their rights
violating the law for personal gain
causing suffering to another person well
and they did it in order to bash and
Destroy for personal gain other like
just the rest of Americans they did it
to hurt all of us they did it to
criminalize
the Trump movement and they did it to
criminalize the Maga movement and they
did this as as I was saying earlier
there was a we experienced a domestic
color revolution in 2020. all the
Hallmarks of whether you want to talk
about maidan which Tim I know you were
you covered live
um whether you want to tell them about
any we're seeing elements of this into
balisi right now in Georgia
um that this was a domestic color
Revolution and some of the same people
like Norm Eisen may still be living
through elements of it uh we're we're
admitted parts of it the man who wrote
the book on color revolutions and he's
in the Time magazine article which came
out one month after January 6th like the
the serial killer writing the letter to
the police I got you and you will never
catch me uh one and then signing it
because they want credit for their work
so when I see all of these things happen
together then January 6 comes out as a
sort of it's almost like a psychological
Justice certification used by the regime
in order to say well this is why we had
to do all of those things don't you see
we had to protect you from this terrible
Movement we had to protect you from
these people these 71 million Americans
who are all domestic terrorists were
going to criminalize this movement we're
going to get rid of you that's why and
you're seeing but you actually are
seeing elements of the the symptoms of
the effects of this from the Republican
party now because you're starting to see
the more establishment types are trying
to go back to Reagan they're trying to
bring him back up again you know we're
really the Reagan party or even seeing
Eisenhower I'm seeing people do this now
like a lot of Zoomers with they always
have a Ukraine flag in their bio and
they say I'm an Eisenhower Republican
right it's like name one thing
Eisenhower did and I don't know why
everybody likes Reagan so much to be
honest and then gun control and no fault
divorce I'm not interested yeah
amnesty make it harder for black
Californians to own guns well yeah like
what but the point being is but the
point being is there it's it's not about
Reagan it's about someone who's not
Trump it's about something is popular
who's not Trump that we can go back to
and use as a way to shade against Trump
which is funny because originally the
The Establishment hated Reagan they were
all behind the bush family
um and that's why you had that election
in 1980 the way you did with where Bush
becomes the vice president after running
of extremely hard race against the uh
the Grassroots populist candidate which
may be something that we see again very
soon here uh I say for no reason
whatsoever that uh
they are attempting to make it painful
and Tim you talked about this once
before you said
if you're watching the Main Street you
when you were talking about the 2020
election I really appreciated your your
diagnosis of what happened that you had
a group of people in this country on the
left that listened to the media and said
all of these terrible horrible things
were happening and they kept ratcheting
up the pressure rashing up the pressure
ratcheting up the pressure the pain and
the psychological torture and then said
If you just vote him out of office
but more than that they then knocked on
your door and said all of the suffering
you're enduring as you're locked in this
building is because of trump here you go
here's the bout to fill out and they
would say you got it thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time